il ya un peu plus d'un an je vous
présente art un ordinateur que j'aimais
beaucoup c'est une innovation d'asus
était le zenbook pro duo et la début
2021 asus arrive avec une toute nouvelle
machine dont la boîte et là c'est le
zenbook duo je peux si vous voyez bien
avec l'éclairage c'est le zenbook duo on
n'est pas sûr modèle pro mais on est sur
une nouvelle génération un nouveau
modèle mis au goût du jour pour 2021 et
je trouve extrêmement bien il vient
corriger certains points notamment au
niveau de l'épaisseur c'était une
machine assez épaisses le zenbook
produit au on apporte pas mal de
nouveautés
d'un point de vue logiciel d'un point de
vue matériel on va regarder tout ça et
croyez moi si vous cherchez une machine
qui est différent science qui est
vraiment différente qui permettra de
faire d'autres choses par rapport à ce
point fr avec un pca tu peut plus
standard et bien il se peut qu'un bouc
duo vous intéresse éveil votre curiosité
moi je l'aimé beaucoup je trouve
vraiment très très très particulier en
plus je suis très heureux parce que
c'est l'ordinateur qui venaient
présenter tout de suite là à l'instant
par asus et que j'ai depuis trois
semaines à peu près à la maison donc
autant vous le dire que j'ai le temps de
faire plaisir avec tous vous débriefer
dans cette vidéo vous êtes règne au
liban
[Musique]
on va commencer par regarder un peu côté
spec
on va faire très très rapidement pour
vraiment parler des usagers de ce qu'on
peut faire vous avez ici en haut un
écran de 14 pouces un écran full hd qui
va jusqu'à 400 x de luminosité vous
pouvez le monte à fond voilà là je suis
au taquet sert d'écran qui est
complètement tactile je peux dire ouvrir
les différentes applications très
facilement
voyez par exemple ici je peux up la
modifier la réduire la déplacer faire ce
que je veux l'emmener en bas mais s'en
va le regarder dans quelques instants
les sages et j'adore c'est vraiment
génial et vous avez un ratio écran
châssis de 93% avec des bords qu'ils
font en 7 mm et 4 mm sur les côtés c'est
très fin c'est mignon c'est pratique ça
j'aime beaucoup ça les crocs et certifié
pantone oeuvre est une langue qui va
lutter contre la lumière bleue et qui a
une gamme de couleurs 100% srgb et vous
avez un deuxième écran qui est situé ici
juste en bas et qui crée toute
l'originalité et tout l'intérêt de ce
produit cet écran s'appelle le scream
pas de plus un écran de 12 pouces c'est
un des croquis et de résolution de 1920
par 515 pixels et qui peut monter
jusqu'à 400 dites ce que vous montrez
les usages dans quelques instants
personnellement j'aime beaucoup on a
vraiment la sensation de profondeur avec
l'écran du haut et je trouve ça vraiment
mais vraiment vraiment super ici on a un
châssis en alliage d'aluminium et
magnésium sont extérieures retrouve le
design typique d'asus avec ces cercles
asymétrique sans ordi qui a cédé j'ai
kiffé 1,6 kg et à peine 16,9 mm
d'épaisseur
mais ce qui fait tout l'intérêt de ce
produit c'est la passementerie l'avenir
s'ouvrir au niveau de la charnière
lorsque vous commencez à l'ouvrir il va
venir prendre un appui derrière ici il
va se lever et ensuite vous avez le
scream pas de plus qui va se lever
jusqu'à un angle de 7 degrés ça ça
plusieurs intérêts le premier s'appelle
pour une meilleure efficacité thermique
puisque vous allez avoir une vraie
dissipation de la chaleur puisque l'air
chaud va pouvoir s'évacuer extrêmement
facilement la dissipation de chaleur en
plus améliorée grâce à de nouveaux
ventilateurs à 59 pâle contre 43 pâle
sur la génération précédente ce qui nous
permettra également de venir préserver
les performances de la machine
et puis faut le reconnaître on a quand
même une bien meilleure expérience au
niveau du screen pas de plus
on a vraiment l'impression d'être dans
la continuité de votre écran et ça vient
vraiment maximiser l'expérience mais ça
ne s'arrête pas là puisque vous avez un
capteur d'inclinaison son amant qui est
inférieur à 80 degrés eh bien il va
venir réduire
la puissance du processeur pour éviter
la chauffe et ça réduira également la
consommation d'énergie et prolongera
l'autonomie donc cette charnière en
alliage de zinc que vous allez retrouver
ici est vraiment avoir plusieurs
bénéfices sur l'expérience visuelle sur
la performance sur la dissipation de la
chaleur
et puis il faut le dire franchement
comme ça c'est beaucoup plus beau à
l'intérieur on va retrouver un intel
core i5 ou i7 2 11e génération vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à 32 gigas de ram
c'est la lpddr2 4x 4260 mégahertz
côté stockage c'est un ssd peut monter
jusqu'à 1 tera maximum pcie 3.0 est
viable et côté graphique vous avez deux
possibilités soit une intel iris et x
graphics soit menée une vidéo geforce mx
450 avec deux gigas de ram gddr5 la
carte graphique permettra d'aller
beaucoup plus loin vous pourrez
notamment jouer en full hd jusqu'à 60
images par seconde mais vous retrouve
également du wifi 6 et du bluetooth 5.0
vous allez trouver ici un lecteur de
cartes microsd une prise jack et une
prise usb à 3.2 une prise hdmi 1.4 deux
ports thunderbolt 4 usb c'est qu'ils
vont jusqu'à 40 gigabits par seconde
vous pourrez donc branché ici deux
moniteurs externes 1 via hdmi et un via
usb c'est vous rechargez en plus votre
ordinateur ici directement en usb c'est
grâce à un block de charge 65 watts
inclus et si vous le voyez sur le blog
de charges américains parce que j'ai un
ordinateur de tests vous vous aurez un
bloc européen si vous êtes en europe
mais bon pour ma part je peux l'utiliser
avec ça je le prends je le mets dedans
ça marche parfaitement bien vous avez à
l'intérieur une batterie de 70 watts
heure en lithium polymère qui vous
permettra de tenir jusqu'à 17h selon
asus alors 17 heures si vous arrivez au
maximum du maximum du maximum
en réalité vous êtes en dessous c'est 17
heures ça dépendra bien évidemment des
programmes vous allez faire tomber
dessus plus trop gourmands et moins
votre machine ira loin dans le temps
mais truc qui est assez intéressant
c'est que vous avez évidemment votre
blog de charge de 65 watts mais vous
pouvez utiliser n'importe quel chargeur
pour dames utiliser une pauvre banques
pour tenir leurs charges est très
facilement ça peut être pratique si vous
êtes en déplacement et pas très
électrique vous avez une grosse power
banque avec vous vous branchez ça vous
permettra de prolonger la durée de vie
de batterie la voix de kad est située
juste ici la voyez là où il ya mon doigt
on est ici uniquement en 720p
asus met en avant son algorithme avec de
l'intelligence artificielle pour venir
améliorer la qualité
en réalité ça vient lycée s'ébruiter pas
si vous enlevez moi plus je l'éclairage
et si j'ai vraiment un très très très
gros claira ski situées juste là ça
vient d'eux
mais des petites parties qu'on retrouve
ici sur le côté salissent sabres 8
on vante les qualités et pour moi le
résultat là dessus n'est pas à la
hauteur au point je trouve pas génial
génial non plus vous avez des hauts
parleurs harman cardon le sang va être
beaucoup trop médium le spectre est pas
très très très large
la qualité est là dessus n'est pas au
rendez vous asus a utilisé la même
recette qui avait très bien fonctionné
avec son asus dell book pro duo ici un
clavier en qwerty parce qu'une fois de
plus une version us mme vous vous aurez
une version azerty soyez tranquille là
dessus tout est vraiment très très serré
ici la partie clavier se trouve là la
partie trackpad ici et vous avez beau ce
crime pas de plus en eau
malgré tout et bien que ce soit serré je
trouve le clavier assez confort au début
j'ai eu un petit peu de mal à le repérer
ya trouvé mais touche forcément les sur
en qwerty pas sur une artiste apprend un
peu plus de temps vous avez une petite
touche hunter qui est située la météo
qu'on a pris le coup c'est très pratique
et très logique
en plus de savourer des touches
fonctions au qui sont vraiment sympas
utilisez vous allez en rive disent
pouvoir venir désactiver votre caméra
switcher ici entre l'écran du haut
l'écran du bas activer désactiver ou
assombrir votre screen pas de plus vous
avez un raccourci vers my asus à f12
activer ou désactiver votre pavé tactile
à m6 régler la luminosité de l'écran
arrive 4e 5 le volume f3 à f2 et vous
l'aurez remarqué on a petit trackpad
situé sur le côté pour utiliser un doigt
de doigts très facilement clic gauche
clic droit
la différence que vous avez ici qu'on
avec le zenbook produit au team manque
c'est un petit peu dommage c'est qu'ici
on n'a pas de nulle part vous ne pouvez
pas venir appuyer avoir retenu mme pas
toutefois que c'était très pratique est
ici voilà ça vient petit peu manqué
peut-être qu'une version pro arrivera
plus tard allez savoir peut-être qui
vous permettrait d'avoir ces
fonctionnalités du num pas de course à
avoir à l'avenir en tout cas ici on ne
l'a pas et ce qui est pratique c'est que
votre clavier vers s'incliner de 4,5
degrés ce qui vous apporte plus de
confort lors de vos saisie on va
s'intéresser scier la partie logicielle
en commençant par windows
ici vous avez le choix entre windows 10
famille windows 10 pro ce qui va
réellement nous intéresser ici nous
c'est toute la partie en bas avec le
screen pas de plus qu'est-ce qu'il vous
apporte quels sont les usages et la
meilleure façon de le voir c'est de
plonger dedans avec ses différentes
fonctionnalités avec ce script a de plus
vous avez beaucoup de possibilités déjà
commencé par la disposition de votre
barre ici moi je les mises en bas mais
je peux la mettre ailleurs si je le
souhaite tout se passe dans centre de
contrôle positionnement par défaut elle
se situe à gauche je vous la remet comme
ça moi je la cage pour qu'elle vienne
pas m'embêter mais vous pouvez la mettre
comme vous souhaitez la faire apparaître
si vous le souhaitez dans un premier
temps pour venir commençait à régler la
luminosité
deux vols ce crime pas de plus bon je
voulais me à fond pour bien voir ce qui
se passe avec cette icône là vous allez
pouvoir voir ce qui se situe en haut de
votre écran mais également en bas de
votre écran
là j'ai aucune application ouverte mais
sur la partie du haut je vais là tous
les programmes qui sont ouverts sur
l'écran du haut et en bas ceux qui sont
ouverts sur le screen pas de plus ici
vous allez voir venir associer votre
téléphone aux scream pad grâce à la
fonction lick my asus dans l'application
mariage est bon ça vous le voyez ça
écrit ici bon moi personnellement je
l'ait pas fait en dessous il pourra
revenir verrouiller ou déverrouiller mon
clavier si je le souhaite mais en
dessous ici j'arrive avec quelques
petites applications qui sont sympas
utilisé je vais notamment avoir mon
quick qui bon ici rien de bien engagé
voire quelques petits raccourcis qui
sont déjà connus je peux venir écrire à
la main par exemple un peu la flemme je
me fais un petit coucou up
j'écris très mal et ça ne me reconnais
je vais retrouver ici mon humeur qui
support ouvrir leurs étoffes
d'applications d'asus ouvrir directement
my asus pour piloter mon ordinateur ou
encore raccourci notamment pour spotify
dont control panel settings que je vais
pouvoir utiliser dans différentes
applications notamment photoshop et je
vous montre dans quelques instants ayant
touché des fonctionnalités qui sont
vraiment sympas qui me permettent
d'enregistrer des dispositions de mon
écran j'ai un groupe à un groupe de un
groupe iii il faut bien créer un groupe
4 très facilement par exemple et si je
clique ça va bien ouvrir non vous pain à
savoir en haut j'ai mon navigateur
internet en dessous j'ai mon bloc-notes
et là j'ai mon explorateur de fichiers
ça correspond donc à une configuration
un usage que j'en ai à un instant t
je veux dire prendre des infos sur
internet je vais les noter là et en
suisse peut naviguer dans les différents
fichiers très facilement mais ça peut
aussi être une autre configuration avec
notamment lightroom qui va s'ouvrir sur
le haut et en bas âge de voir mon
navigateur internet on vient chercher
notamment des tuto sur lightroom pour
deux choses que je ne connaîtrais pas ou
pour venir m'inspirer troisième groupe
par exemple ça va être premiere pro en
eau tout mon navigateur avec tous mes
ruches embarqués pouvant dire importer
après à vous y retrouver la
configuration idéale en fonction de vos
usages tout en sachant vous avez
plusieurs possibilités voulait vraiment
répartir comme vous le souhaitez soit
une seule appli en eau soit 2 à pliant
aux soit 3 appli quelle que soit la
configuration voire même carrément 4
applis en bas une seule grande appli
trois appuis deux applis et or si vous
faites deux tiers un tiers un tiers 2/3
comme vous souhaitez vous aurez vos
applications vous appliquez ça marche et
ça c'est cool et ensuite vous arrivez
dans vos différents paramètres notamment
lié à l'affichage de vos scream pas de
plus la luminosité ça je voulais déjà
montré votre arrière plan pour venir
changer ça vous permettra de choisir une
photo dans vos fichiers intel sombre ou
un thème clair personnellement je
préfère de loin
le thème sondre votre centre de contrôle
qui situe la masquer automatiquement
votre centre de contrôle si vous le
souhaitez wii ou pas peuvent ainsi
personnaliser le centre de contrôle
comme vous le souhaitez vous y retrouver
le contrôle des fenêtres c'est pas mal
d'options encore m vous pouvez venir à
réduire la luminosité du scream pas de
plus en mode économiseur de matri vous
avez également un guide rapide avec
différentes vidéos qui vous permettront
de voir comment l'utiliser très
facilement ses didactique et c'est très
pratique
là je vais vous montrer en usa ce que je
trouve vraiment génial en utilisant
photoshop est en train de travailler sur
une vidéo qui raconte les aventures ça
va cartonner que j'ai fait pour amazon
voyez donc ici la miniature de la vidéo
qui sortira d'ici quelques jours
est ce que je trouve vraiment génial
c'est que voyez en bas là sûrement ce
crime pas de plus j'ai un centre de
contrôle qui permet de venir contrôler
différentes fonctions dans photoshop je
peux les paramétrer des départs peut
mettre ce que je veux comme je veux
la notamment ici j'ai une petite molette
qui permet de venir zoom est très
facilement je viens où je veux je zoome
jeu des zooms je trouve ça vraiment très
très très très pratique j'ai différents
outils ici choisir notamment l'outil la
soul ou type iep est l'outil pièce
l'outil forme
vous pouvez bien le configurer
différentes manières en fonction de vos
usages de vos besoins vous l'avez sous
photoshop vous l'avez également sur
lightroom classique vous l'avez
notamment sur premiere pro je trouve cet
outil vraiment bien pensé très malin et
ça vient apporter une fois de plus de
nouvelles fonctionnalités autres il pas
de plus avoir un grand ordinateur comme
ça avoir inscrit pas de plus tout ça
vraiment super bien qu'aux tables qui
clôt whaou what the fuck quand on est un
technophile tout de suite on
s'émerveille devant une machine comme ça
maintenant la question c'est les usages
qu est ce que vous allez pouvoir en
faire vous aimons très différents usages
la répartition de différentes
applications comme vous le souhaitez
mais en réalité vous qu'est ce que vous
allez en faire d'ailleurs avant je vous
en parle un peu plus dites moi vous ce
que vous pensez vous allez pouvoir en
faire à quel usage vous verrez derrière
moi la toute première faisait ce qu'il
sait tout de suite aux yeux c'est un
ordinateur qui décide et plus aux
créatifs vous avez un lecteur de cartes
microsd vous faites tourner très
facilement photoshop lightroom toute la
suite adoubi en réalité est que ce soit
premiere pro et compagnie si vous êtes
créatif ve vous aurez vraiment de quoi
faire avec une machine qui saura vous
contenter en font bien évidemment de la
configuration vous allez prendre mais
également pour la productivité ce ça
extrêmement intéressante vous mettez ça
vaut ce crime pas de plus vos emails que
vous avez tout le temps sous les yeux en
vous travaillez sur une présentation sur
powerpoint sur word ou à faire des
calculs sur excel douleur dans n'importe
quelle application peu importe
prévenez vraiment répartir vos fenêtres
comme vous le souhaitez donc pouvoir des
usages un usage productivité
et un usage montage un usage édition de
photos ce qui est vraiment super avec
cette configuration écran ce crime pas
de plus c'est la modularité vous et
pouvoir avoir et l'évolutivité vous
allez pouvoir donner dans le temps en
fonction des usages sur des usages ça
évolue sur des pouvoir adapter cette
machine à vos besoins aujourd'hui mais
également dans le futur je ne suis pas
convaincu par la qualité des haut
parleurs ça c'est un petit peu dommage
pour l'aspect multimédia bien vous
puissiez faire tourner des jeux dessus
ce n'est pas un ordinateur qui va être
dédiée pour gaming vous avez une gamme
rog chez asus avec un ordinateur assez
similaire pour le gaming vous permettra
d'avoir plus de performances et d'aller
plus loin si vous êtes vraiment gamer
peut-être faut-il vous diriger vers
cette machine sur laquelle devait
parvenir incorporez ensuite des usages
de productivité à réfléchir en fonction
de vos priorités il vos besoins j'aime
beaucoup cette proposition faite par
asus elle est vraiment différente et une
fois de plus ce que je tiens vraiment à
souligner c'est l'épaisseur on se
rapproche des ultraportables on est
quand même sur une machine qui a deux
écrans avec une partie clavier screen
pas de plus qui vient pivoter ses fins
c'est super bien fait très bien
maîtrisée personnellement j'aime
beaucoup à vous de me dire vous ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
qu'est ce que vous pensez de l'asus
mboup duo version 2021 la référence
d'ailleurs gelé quelque part ici c'est
le x 480 2h06 une machine qui sera
disponible dans le commerce à partir de
mars 2021 il faut encore un petit peu
s'armer de patience vous allez pouvoir
retrouver sur le stand asus mais
également dans le commerce dans le
retail une fois que ce sera possible je
mettrai les liens en bas dans la
description et c'est une machine qui est
disponible au times up à partir de 100
to 1799 euros
je n'ai pas l'état y est détaillé pour
les différentes configurations tu
machine était toute nouvelle mais déjà à
partir de 1799 euros vous allez
commencer à pouvoir vous faire plaisir
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire et quand elle se retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parer tech
parce qu'il ya plein de choses qui
arrivent
et ça c'est qu'on a très vite mis look
d'abord tel chaos